I began to understand that the goal of
psychic development by which he means
psychological development
or spiritual development
is the self.
There is no linear evolution.
There's only a circumambulation
of itself a getting closer.
It's like,
it's like you're spiraling into something,
something like that and the thing that
you're spiraling into recedes as you move
towards it and it gets more and more
sophisticated and well developed as you
move towards it because you're not going
to run out of goals,
right?
No matter how much you
have your act together,
there's probably undoubtedly 30 dimensions
along which you could get your act
together a lot more so.
And some of those aren't even conceivable
to you when you're in your initial on
carved state,
let's say uniform development
exists at most at the beginning.
Later,
everything points towards the center.
This insight gave me stability and
gradually my inner peace returned.
So this is fun.
On the left there,
that's the sharp cathedral.
That's the one that has the maze
in it that I told you about.
They actually light that up with lasers
now and so that's it lit up with lasers.
And so,
so it,
it,
they're turning it into
a cathedral of light,
which I think is really fascinating.
And it's a,
it's a continuation of the same idea,
right?
Because the stain glass windows where
obviously I wouldn't call them primitive
attempts to do that.
I mean,
stained glass windows
are pretty impressive.
You know,
buddy,
it's an elaboration of the same thing.
So now you can go to that Cathedral.
They light up the whole town like that,
which is really something.
And so there,
and there is how the cathedral is built.
It's across.
Um,
and do you remember the cross is an ax
that marks the center of the world and
the cross is the place
where each individual is.
And I think that's the fundamental
message of Christianity is the Crossmark's
the place where every
single individual is.
And it's a tragic place that consists of
suffering and exposure to malevolence.
And that the only way to come to
terms with it is to accept it.
And that seems to me,
I don't see anything metaphysical
about that statement whatsoever.
It's like,
well,
x marks the spot.
Fair enough.
You're in a spot.
You're right in the center of your world.
It's written the center of the
world as far as you're concerned.
And the same with the rest of us.
It's characterized by suffering
and exposure to malevolence.
There's no doubt about that.
What are you going to do about that?
Bitter,
resentful,
hateful.
All that does is make it worse.
So you have to accept it.
Now that's not an easy thing
because that's actually,
I would say,
a heroic task to voluntarily accept
the conditions of your own existence.
And that happens at the cross.
So that's fine.
And that's associated with light.
Well that's good that that's
associated with light.
You wouldn't want that to
be associated with darkness.
That would be a bad thing.
So,
and so there's the,
there's the,
uh,
the labyrinth that was built in 1,280.
And so the idea is you walk in here,
it's the same idea as that star sequence
of slides that I just showed you.
So here's the idea,
is that north,
south,
west,
and east.
So that's the whole world
laid out in two dimensions.
And so the question is how
do you get to the center?
Now we already know what the center is.
The center is the center of the cross.
That's the place of maximal suffering.
You could say maximal malevolence as well,
but it's also the place
where that's transcended.
So how do you get there?
While the answer is,
well,
you don't just stand on
the outside looking in,
that's not going to help.
So,
and you can't just run right to the
center even if you're in California.
And so
you have to walk in here and then you
see you go like this and you go to every
single place,
every single place on that,
on that little cosmos.
And then once you've gone to every
single place and expanded yourself as a
consequence of going north
and west and east and south,
then there's enough of
you so that you're at,
so that you can tolerate being first of
all that you could figure out where the
center is,
but also that you can
tolerate being at the center.
And so that's what that represents.
And that's pretty.
And look,
I mean,
let's make no mistake about it.
Hey,
people were pretty damn
serious about those ideas.
Like that's uh,
that's quite the piece of work for people
in the 12th century in all of those,
some of those damn cathedrals
took 300 years to build.
We don't build anything
that takes 300 years.
You know,
and people were putting a lot of effort
into whatever these things meant,
you know,
and if you think they meant
bearded man in the sky,
then you know,
it's hard to,
it's hard to account for the kind of
motivation that would produce these
buildings with that kind of
paucity of conceptualization.
You know,
the towns,
and it was certainly the case in charters
that they groaned under the tax burden
that was required to produce these.
Now you might think,
well that's partly tyrannical
and no doubt that's the case,
but,
but that's not the whole story.
The whole story is that the people
who produce those buildings,
they thought about every bit of it is
nothing's accidental and they're trying to
portray something just like that
window is trying to portray something.
That's the same thing as this.
It's the center from which all
things manifest themselves.
You see it,
that's Christ.
They're being portrayed as,
as that center or the center within him,
something like that.
Very much like the shocker is,
and in,
in a,
in a yoga practice,
same basic idea.
It's the opening up of the
internal structure and,
and its proper realization.
So
there are people walking the
labyrinth.
So that's the coat of many colors,
right?
That's,
that's this differentiated motive being
that enables you to be competent at,
at home in the widest
possible number of places.
And that that's a real
differentiation of your personality.
It's breaking through the
boundaries of your personality,
including the ones that you
impose on yourself to become
someone who is useful
wherever they're put.